next question Gilbert hi simply put I've
dropped out of a college after trying to
graduate for four years I work a
part-time job but I'm still semi and
semi dependent on my strict Asian
parents who are insistent on keeping me
on finishing my degree oh how can I go
how do I break the news to them no not
be graduating and how do I find your
direct man I'll [ __ ] listen to me
right now okay
his name is Peter I don't give a [ __ ]
bro alright
my parents my brother and I changed them
they try to change us oh you have to go
to college or you have to be an engineer
we have to do no nope we're gonna do
drugs
alright we're gonna [ __ ] you know we're
gonna do what we want and then you know
what they did because oh okay I guess
over time what are you gonna do either
cut us off right or accept our lifestyle
well I'm not gonna [ __ ] go to college
for you mom cuz I don't know how to do
it I don't know before I've never read I
don't know anything
alright so it's like no just a lesson
they finished let me finish okay let me
[ __ ] finish alright so I don't do
really leavin listen to the thing
halfway through it I know you did but I
want to just say this okay it is that
you can change them let me tell you
something right now I know a comic by
the name I'm not gonna say his name by
Noah comic he was an engineer he was
making six figures a year he's a great
comic he happens to be Middle Eastern
right that has nothing to do it but his
dad's very strict his dad wants him to
still be an engineer but this kid has so
much talent he just can't
it's it would be a shame to the world
for him not to do it right so he chose
comedy alright he's he's doing well
enemies making a living and his dad
still doesn't like it and he is you know
but what is he gonna do do what his
dad's does this is your life if my kid
if coal oil and I didn't kill babies we
would have probably a couple
why do you keep accusing okay we didn't
kill it we didn't kill anybody
aren't you glad we don't have one with
this new president I know but please
don't say that oh please don't say that
but what I'm gonna say this is this is
that if my child goes hey Dad I'm gonna
be a I'm gonna make clogs what yeah
that's why I'm going to clogs making
school and I'll be like what okay that's
what my son or daughter does you know I
want them to be you know a professional
soccer player or whatever my dream is
and for my child to be like I want you
to be you know you know some soccer
player and anime or whatever right but
if they want to do something that I
didn't envision that's their life okay
and I just I I spent too many years
fighting with my parents like Oh your
cousin Qiong is she going to Hollywood
at dinner table and then trying to make
me feel like [ __ ] because I didn't go to
college you know I you know I I remember
in report card good days I knew that if
I brought home my report card to my
parents that it was 100% I'm gonna get
beat so one time I think was my
sophomore year in high school there's a
cool that we lived on a gigantic kind of
mountain not a mountain but like you
know was uphill fancy Country Club it
wasn't okay it was a nice community but
you could go into like the woods and
there was like a little clip that you
can jump up you died right I wrote one
time I had my report card in my hand and
I was on the cliff and I was gonna jump
off Jesus because I would rather kill
myself didn't the face my parents cuz I
got a couple of C's and a D on a report
card but I would always come home with
my report card and they I would get the
beating I would cry I'd be in my room
and then I would do drugs but my point
is is this is that at the end of the day
you know my parents are very glad that I
chose my career but that's the exception
to the rule not everybody who says [ __ ]
you mom I'm not going to college makes
the amount of money you do now as a
comedian so no it's not about
say money I didn't say money what I'm
saying is is that you know as soon as I
just started doing stand-up and did what
I wanted to do number one it gave me
imagine not going to college and you
have no skills
you don't want you're lazy you don't
want to work and you're like what the
[ __ ] do I do right so if I'm gonna
struggle in life and I'm gonna be broke
I might as well do something that I
enjoy doing which is I enjoy performing
and it worked out for me I believe that
if anybody if people really enjoy what
they do and they do with passion and
with dedication that inevitably
something's gonna happen he wants to go
into entertainment comedy yeah well then
do it he has a plan so that's my thing
with if if I had a seventeen-year-old
tell me like [ __ ] college I'm just gonna
do nothing I'm not gonna take that as an
option you can come to me with with
saying [ __ ] college if you show me an
alternate plan of action if you say yeah
I'm gonna save this much money and I'm
gonna travel for two years and I'm gonna
figure [ __ ] out when I come back okay
fine that's fine with me
if you say I'm taking this I'm moving to
LA and I'm gonna you know I'm not gonna
need your financial support I'm gonna
work as in a restaurant and try to make
it in the business that's fine now if
you come with me and you say I don't
know what I'm gonna do but I need you to
support me financially [ __ ] you kid
[ __ ] no that's not acceptable you're
going to college you know what I mean
like and you're gonna figure out some
time while you're over there what you
want to do but in the meantime no you
don't get to sit around and do nothing
you know no I'm right I ran into this
problem when only six years ago my
parents so if people don't know I
actually dropped out of school but I
remember when I had to tell my parents I
was gonna go to Chicago I'm gonna do
comedy I'm gonna do that be an actor I
came so I'm so so afraid to tell my
parents did in a restaurant a public
place just so I know I wouldn't get hit
by a chair I made sure I was surrounded
by people in a Japanese restaurant yeah
how did you tell so they were eating
sushi I literally have like so my mom's
probably laughing listen to this I was
so scared mom and dad probably 1918-19
it I had a I made a PowerPoint
presentation I printed it out I'll tell
you why I did that because I heard Emma
Stone did it for her mom then I forgot
she did it to her white mother who was
like okay cause like my parents are
gonna do that I took it out I just as
soon as I took out the papers I said
yeah so I have this dream I want to act
and I think I should stop school I just
pushed it I didn't make eye contact with
my mom my dad and my dad's like mmm 8:08
a California roll and my mom would even
look at me so eventually worked out
something where like I couldn't be
rebellious to just run away that's just
not how I am with my family I know some
people can do that I worked out
something or say okay I'll go to
Community College I did that but
basically I just [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
around just bought time free that's how
while I was in Chicago doing all that
stuff and eventually I had to prove it
to my parents they didn't really talk to
me for almost 2 or 3 years he was like
on and off yeah awkward relationship the
campus Chicago saw me one week where I
was in five shows back to back with a
full packed audience saw the shows flew
back to Atlanta I got calls from them
individually where they were like we get
it yeah after that they're like you're
gonna do it do it right move to LA I got
the same exact thing when I did The
Tonight Show yeah I was out of a 40 seat
theater yeah with a 40 seat live show it
was the same principle though yeah both
stories it was a great story [ __ ]
40 shows in front of [ __ ] coffee shop
yeah you heard the Korean Trump Wow you
got kids they want to get hurt
say that again you're the Korean Toronto
okay we're done there's for tonight mmm
okay that's hurt tell me tell me another
glorious story of yours I would just
spell of your glorious stories
[Music]